階段が、のぼりたい（？）
なんかたくさん階段上ろうと思ってTwitterで打ったんですよ、
「リツイートされた分階段を上ります」って打って、
もうすぐ10時に締め切りって打ったんですけども、
今が時間が9時59分、
あと、1分でございます。
10時までの間に、どれだけリツイートされたかで、僕が階段どれだけ上るかを決めます。
（アラーム音）
あ！10時になりました！
これが最後の更新です。
はい、
（効果音）
（過呼吸）
やばい
♪～
2万か…
（撮影者）たぶんこの辺から…
ここだよ、これだよね？たぶん
こっからスタートだな
こっからっすね、こっから上っていくと、
階段がめちゃくちゃ続いているので、稼げます。
すみません、えっとTwitterだと「上ります」って言っちゃったんですけど、
あの下りも入れないと多分時間が足んないんで、
下りのほうがキツイんでしょ階段って？
下りも込めて、階段の上り下りを20839段繰り返します。
はっ・・・ははは（苦笑）
1159だから、上り下りするだけで、上り下りするとこの値になりますと。
20839を2318で割って、これで往復分が出るってことでしょう。
2318？　で、8.99だから、9往復すれば目標達成です。
もうほぼ9往復でしょう。9往復すると20862段階段を上り下りしたことになります。
この階段を、9往復、
するよ。
（効果音）
リツイートされた分だけ、階段、上り下り、スタート！！
（笛）
♪～　　（階段を上る足音）
（撮影者）そんな速い（笑）？
最初は比較的ね
（効果音）
（速い呼吸）
（おじさん）すごいなぁ
いやぁ～頑張ります！
（おじさん）おぅ、頑張れ！
よっしゃぁ～
最初に飛ばしすぎると死ぬかなあ？
ちょっと待って…
はぁ…はぁ…ちょっと待って
（撮影者）あれ？
ちょっと待って、　はぁ…はぁ… ヤバい
っしゃぁ
（効果音）
ナメてたね
さぁ行きますわ
わぁ…これで…これで片道でしょ
上からはこんな景色だよお
というわけで、これで今やっと1159段
はぁ…はぁ…　よし！
じゃあ戻ります。
（撮影者）（笑い）
やっとここまで…　　（撮影者）あともうちょいです
あ、まだか
（効果音）
（撮影者）よし
（撮影者）2318段
え、マジキツイんだけど。
もう無理かも…
（撮影者）ダメです！
2往復目入ってきます！
（ナレーション）先はまだまだ長い。これを後、8回繰り返すのである。
（ナレーション）果たして彼は無事20,839段の階段を
制覇するこどができるのだろうか？
次回予告！！
（ナレーション）疲れ切る俺！
（小学生たち）キャーーー！　　（ナレーション）小学生たちにすごい騒がれる俺！
（ナレーション）割と足に限界で折れそうな俺！
（ナレーション）ぶっ倒れちゃった俺！
（ナレーション）そこら辺の部活でトレーニングにきてるやつらに任せる俺！
いいなぁ…俺楽しくねえもん。
（ナレーション）乞うご期待！！
♪～（エンディング曲）